Hello, how are you? Sal and Jaramillo greet you
with your brief information for today, Monday
, July 12, we had rains around
the valley last night,
these rains were
accompanied by thunder, a tenth of a drop of water was reported
near the McCain airport, this is
the most  high registered during the
month of July since 1937
, however, even with this rain, the
heat wave continues in the city in which they come
and asks residents to conserve
energy, in particular, to try to
minimize consumption between 6 in the
morning and  9 at night this is to
avoid power cuts in addition to saving
money in your bills it is recommended that you
turn off the lights that you are not using
turn off the motor of the pool from
plugs electronic devices even
avoid using washing machines and dishwashers often
the day in bing launches  a new design
for the driver's license these
include a view of the city of las
vegas on the front side and quad bikes themselves
and on the back  It is the
characteristic mark of the British change from
a circle to the territorial format of the
state of nowhere. Drivers will be able to
obtain the new model once they
renew their license for procedures such as
updating the name or address or they
will have to wait until the
expiration date
and now  We turn to the
weather forecast, another very hot day is expected, the
maximum will be around 114 degrees, it
is important to take great care and
water, just as we can see another round of
rain, strong winds and lightning
for today, beautiful 10 today I went out
Jaramillo and  This was his brief
informative of illusion in Spanish
[Music]